JOSHUA CHA: Hello, and thank
you for joining us today.
My name is Joshua.
And on behalf of
Sundar, we'd like
to welcome you to the
second in a series of three
webinars jointly produced
by Google and Intel.
The goal of these
webinars is to teach you
more about our
collective IoT efforts.
During the broadcast, if
you have any questions,
please type them
into the chat window.
We'll get to those questions
at the end of the webinar.
Until then, please
enjoy the proceedings.
Hello, my name is Joshua
Cha, Cloud Architect
and Program Manager in
the Google Cloud Partner
Engineering Team.
Welcome to the second in the
three part webinar series.
MARTIN KRONBERG: And I'm Martin
Kronberg, Technical Evangelist
with Intel.
So in the previous
webinar, we learned
how to take all the data
generated by our gateway
and send it up to GCP.
And in this webinar, we're
going to show you guys
how to make that data useful.
JOSHUA CHA: By the
end of this talk,
we will have answered
the following questions.
First, how can we make all this
data coming in from our devices
useful?
Now, how do I manage
these devices at scale?
And lastly, how can
GCP make it easy
for me to set up my own global,
high-speed data ingestion
service?
To answer these
questions, we're going
to take your data on a journey.
And the map of the
journey looks like this.
What you see here is a series
of Google Cloud Services,
each with its own role to play.
This pipeline takes your
data from point A to point B.
In the previous
webinar, we learned
how to use the
Intel NUC, send data
into Google Cloud IoT Core.
That data ends up
in a Pub/Sub queue.
From the Pub/Sub queue, we'll
use a Cloud Dataflow pipeline
to take that data from the queue
into a durable storage service
called BigQuery.
And from BigQuery, we'll
visualize that data
using Cloud Data Studio to
create wonderful dashboards
for your users.
But before we dive in, let
me throw it back to Martin
to talk about the
hardware setup.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Sure.
So I just want to take
a quick look again
at how the sensor data is
actually getting into GCP.
So for this demo, we're
using the sensor data that's
coming from our gateway here.
And we have our gateway attached
to an Arduino 101, which
we're using at the Sensor Hub.
Attached to this hub are
three environmental sensors--
temperature, light, and sound.
In order to read
the sensor data,
we're using the MRAA and
UPM libraries from Intel.
We can use a really
simple high-level API
to connect to the Sensor
Hub, and then read out
our values from the sensors.
If you want to learn more
about these libraries
and how you can use
them, please refer back
to the first webinar
of the series.
So Josh, do you want to
tell us a little bit more
about that data journey?
JOSHUA CHA: Absolutely.
Before we begin, I'd like
to take a minute just
to explain a little bit
about our global network.
Now, this is important
because your devices could
be deployed all over the world.
And this has implications in how
your devices communicate back
to the Cloud.
What you're seeing here is
a map of our global network.
You'll notice we have over
100 peering locations.
What this means is
that most likely
we'll have a presence
in the country
where your devices
are deployed into.
This also means that with
a single global IP address
you can send all your data
to that single IP address,
and Google will
automatically load
balance that traffic for you.
So data can come in to
the closest POP, or point
of presence, ride our
backbone, and into the services
in the specific region that
service was set up into.
Let's talk about
the first service
to explore on our journey.
And this is Pub/Sub, our
globally-distributed,
highly-scaled messaging service.
When data is sent
to Google Cloud IoT,
it ends up in a Pub/Sub topic.
Multiple subscribers can
subscribe to these topics
and retrieve information.
It's a durable
service, meaning we
will retain unacknowledged
messages for up to seven days.
It's a global service,
as well, meaning
you could write to a
single URL or IP address,
and Google will handle the
load balancing for you.
Coupled with either
Dataflow or Cloud Functions,
Pub/Sub is your on-ramp
to real-time streaming
into the Cloud.
Let me demonstrate how easy it
is to set up your own topic.
I'll also set up a
simple subscription.
So what you see here is the
Google Cloud Pub/Sub user
interface.
To get there, on
your GCP landing page
you would simply click
on the hamburger menu
and select Pub/Sub.
To create a topic, you
would select Create a Topic.
And then define your own topic.
In this case, let's
just call it Demo.
Click on Create.
And just that easy
you've created a topic.
But it doesn't really
do anything useful
until you can create
a subscription.
To create a subscription,
simply go into the Demo topic
that you just created.
And then click on
Create Subscription.
In this case, we'll
just call it Demo.
And there you have it.
You have your first topic
and subscription duo.
So lets do something
useful with this.
Now, we've been sending
data from the end point
here into Pub/Sub.
Let's see what that looks like.
And in this case, I will issue
the simple g call command
to pull data from
that subscription
or to an existing subscription
I have that received
the data from the end point.
And there you go.
This is the data being
sent from the sensors
to the NUC through IoT
cloud through Pub/Sub.
And there you have it
in the subscription.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Yeah.
Pretty straightforward.
You know, Josh, you
talked about scaling up
your data infrastructure
using the global GCP network.
And as you scale up the
Cloud in the back-end,
you're also going to want
to scale up your hardware
deployments in order to
gather more sensor data,
be able to enact any commands
that you want to send down.
So as you do this, having a
gateway is going to be key.
So the gateway acts
as a central hub
for all of the sensors and
actuators in a local area.
You can send the data gathered
from any number of sensors
using any kind of interface.
For instance, if
you're scaling out
to a factory that has a lot of
legacy sensors, by which I mean
sensors that do not
have a way of connecting
to the Cloud
themselves, you're going
to need a device that
can connect to the Cloud
and act as a data collection
and communication hub.
So Intel has gateway
solutions that
can interface with sensors
over a the local area network,
or using a serial connection,
like Modbus for Cambus,
or short range radios like
Bluetooth, ZIGBEE, or ZWAVE,
as well as many more
connection types.
So by having a single
connection point to the Cloud
you're going to
inherently increase
the security of your deployment.
You limit possible
points of intrusion.
You're going to limit the
number of certificates
you have to manage.
And you can use the
gateway to set up
a firewall that only allows
certain protocols through using
an IP table.
Overall, it's going
to be much more
secure than trying to manage
a multitude of connections.
You could also run some data
preprocessing at the gateway
before shipping it to the
Cloud, from basic things
like taking an average over
time to much more complex data
transformations.
And I want to come
back to this point
a little bit later on
with a few examples.
Finally, as the scale
of your data increases,
you're going to want to also
make sure that it's consistent.
So consistent data
is going to be easier
to parse, as well as to manage.
And the gateway
can also package up
that data for consistent
Cloud congestion.
So in our case, and in many
Cloud connection use cases,
we're using JSON to send
the data back and forth.
So this data transfer method
is easy for humans to read.
And it's easy for
machines to parse.
It's also quickly
becoming a standard
for IoT data transport.
So you'll be able to interface
with many different services
using the same data pipeline.
Another aspect of
scaling out your project
is scaling out the scope of
what the project itself can do.
So in order to help
developers really expand
the capabilities
of their projects,
we have a so-called
path-to-product at Intel.
What the
path-to-product provides
is code samples,
proof of concepts,
as well as market research into
specific verticals in the IoT
space, including Smart
Home, transportation,
autonomous driving, so on.
It's all open source.
And it's all up on GitHub
under MIT licensing.
So you can use what
you need from our code.
Josh, do you want to
tell us a little bit more
about what the data
can do in BigQuery?
JOSHUA CHA: Absolutely.
So BigQuery is my
favorite GCP product.
Now, in the journey,
you'll see that we're
going to skip over Dataflow.
And we'll get back
to that in a second.
You'll see why.
For now, let's talk
about BigQuery.
BigQuery is Google's
analytics database that's
built for petabyte-scale.
It's ideal for the
analytics use cases
because you don't have to worry
about deploying more resources
when you're constantly
pumping in more IoT data
from these devices.
It's fully managed,
No-Ops Data Warehouse.
It's built for
petabyte-scale as mentioned,
but it's super fast
at the same time.
You get the convenience of SQL.
So if you're used
to writing SQL,
you'll be able to work
with BigQuery easily.
And finally, it's an
externalized version
of Google Dremel, which is
a database we've been using
internally for over a decade.
So it's been hardened.
It's been tested.
And it's been put
into production
for well over 10 years now.
So let me demonstrate
how easy it
is to set up your own database
and issue some simple commands.
So the first thing you'll
notice is that you're
using SQL constructs here.
So you're going to select
star from this table.
Order by ascending order.
Click on Run Create.
It's going to run the query.
And notice how fast it was.
This table has over 7,000 rows.
Let's try it in
descending order.
Run the same query to see
the data change a bit.
And there you go.
Right?
So it's going to sort
this in descending order.
Notice how super fast it was.
To create a table, again,
click on this down arrow.
Super fast.
We're going to create a dataset.
And we're just going
to call it demo.
Click on OK.
And from the demo, you
can create a new table.
And you can either
create it from source
or create an empty table.
Let's just create an empty
table, and call it demo table.
Keep that in mind.
We'll get back to
that in a little bit.
And just add a couple of fields.
Let's try timestamp,
which is an integer.
And let's try temperature,
which is a float here.
So I'm going to click
on Create Table.
And there you have it,
your first BigQuery table.
Now that we have data
coming into Pub/Sub,
and we have a place
to store that data,
how do we get that data from
the Pub/Sub topic into BigQuery?
There are a few options,
but today, we'll
focus on Cloud Dataflow.
If you are familiar
with Apache Beam,
then you'll feel right at
home with Cloud Dataflow.
Cloud Dataflow is a
fully managed service
for transforming and enriching
data in stream or real-time
or in batch historical
with equal reliability
and expressiveness.
So no more complex workarounds
or compromises needed.
At a high level,
you define a source,
which we call inbound data
and a sync, outbound data.
When you bring data in,
it becomes a collection
in which a pipeline of
operations, which we call
transforms, can be performed.
The data source can be
batch or it can be streamed.
And there is a time
windowing concept which
allows for great extensibility.
You do all of this under a
single programming model,
which reduces complexity.
Before we go to
a demo, I'm going
to throw it back to Martin
to talk a little bit more
about ETL.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Sure.
So there's going to be three
main parts of data handling
that the gateway does for us--
the extraction,
transformation, and loading
of data, or ETL as it's
referred to in data science.
We discussed the
extraction of data
or gathering the sensor data.
We talked about
the loading of data
or ingesting it into
Google Cloud Platform.
Now, I want to talk
a little bit more
about the transformation
of the data.
So raw data is going
to be a little rough.
There's going to be outliers.
There's going to be some noise.
And there's going to be
a time series of data
that follows certain trends.
When we're dealing with
a massive amount of data,
as a large-scale
industrial deployment will,
we want to be able to clean that
data up as fast as possible.
So to facilitate
this process, Intel
has developed a set of libraries
called the Data Analytics
Acceleration Libraries or DAAL.
These libraries cover a vast
amount of data transformation
methods--
linear regression,
outlier detection,
and low order moments, or
things like means, sums,
standard deviations.
So these are just a
few of the core tools
that a data scientist can
use to transform raw data.
And all of these
tools and many more
are provided by
the DAAL library.
And using that you can transform
your raw data into something
more usable that can then be
fed into our Cloud Analytics
pipeline.
So these libraries
have been optimized
to run on Intel
architecture in order
to provide an extremely
fast way to transform
large amounts of data.
And the best part is that
DAAL runs on Hadoop, Spark, R,
and Matlab.
So that means that you can
use the data processing
pipeline with which you
are most familiar with.
If you want to try out these
libraries for yourself,
go to
software.intel.com/Intel-DAAL
to download the libraries,
read about how to use them,
and try them out.
JOSHUA CHA: Now that we have
the ETL performing on the Intel
device itself, we can
still use Dataflow
to transfer the data from
Pub/Sub topic into BigQuery.
Let's see how.
To get to Cloud Dataflow.
You click on the hamburger
menu and click on Dataflow.
In order to have a number
of services already running,
this particular
pipeline is running
to take the data from
this device from the topic
and into BigQuery.
To create a new
pipeline, I simply
create a job from template.
Now, we're using a
template here because we
don't have to do anything
sophisticated here
because the NUC here is
going to handle the ETL.
I give this a name.
I'm going to use the
third option, which
is Cloud Pub/Sub to BigQuery.
And after selecting this option,
I'm going to select two more--
I need to provide two
more pieces of detail.
One is the actual topic.
Since I have my Pub/Sub
topic already opened here,
I'm going to select this topic.
And from BigQuery, I'm
going to select this table.
Now you know why we
skipped over Cloud Dataflow
and went directly to BigQuery.
Two
So now that we have the
BigQuery table defined,
we click on Run Job.
And there you go.
That's your first Cloud
Dataflow pipeline taking data
from a Pub/Sub topic
and into BigQuery.
At this point, we've
covered a lot of ground.
So let's quickly review
what we've done thus far.
On our data journey,
we started out
with the sensor information
coming into Cloud IoT Core.
From there, the data got
into a Pub/Sub topic.
Just now, we create a
pipeline to take that data
from the topic
and into BigQuery.
Now, with the data
in BigQuery, we
can move on to the
last step, which
is using Cloud Data Studio,
which is a free tool that
allows you to make beautiful
charts from your streaming
data.
Instead of me talking,
let me walk you
through a simple example.
To get to Data
Studio, you simply
go to DataStudio.Google.com.
To start, click on
the big blue plus
button to start a new dashboard.
The first step when
you create a dashboard
is to create your
first data source.
In this case, I'm going to
create one from my GCP project.
You click on this
big blue button.
And you'll notice that
Data Studio offers
a number of data connectors.
This makes it easy to
connect your data sources.
In this case, we're
going to use BigQuery.
And because I've logged
in with my GCP account,
it knows which projects
I have access to.
In this case, we'll be
connecting to the Intel webinar
project as appropriate.
Click on Edge Data.
And here's that demo
BigQuery table we created.
Here's Edge Data, Data Table.
And I'm going to
click on Connect
and connect this data source.
What you'll notice here is
that I didn't code up anything.
What Data Studio did was looked
into that BigQuery table,
found the columns,
and automatically
created these metrics for me.
It's smart enough to identify
that light was number,
sound was a number,
temperature is a number.
Even the timestamp,
which is specified
as an integer in BigQuery,
it was identified
as a date, which is correct.
Here, I'm going to change
just a few parameters around.
I'm going to make these
averages instead of sums.
And let's add a bit
more detail to the time
here to include both
the day and the hour,
just to make it a
bit more interesting.
I'm going to add
that to the report.
And OK?
Here's your first dashboard.
Let's create a table that
just takes the raw data
and dumps it to this screen.
To do so, I click
on this table icon.
Draw up the table
in the dashboard.
And you'll notice immediately
the time stamps are already
populated here.
It added light, but we could
add a couple of other metrics.
And let's add sound.
And lastly, let's
add temperature.
And there you go.
So now you have a data
dump of information
coming from the sensor.
But let's create a chart now to
make it a bit more attractive.
So I'm going to start with
this time series chart.
It's essentially a line chart.
I'm going to drag
into the dashboard.
And you'll notice
that on the x-axis
it'll automatically populate
it with a time stamp.
By default, it's
adding the light,
but we could add the sound.
And let's also add
the temperature.
And there you have it.
In about five minutes we
created a beautiful table
with all your data
and a chart that
gives it a bit more meaning
than just a list of raw numbers.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Yeah,
so this visualization
looks really great.
And I'm guessing that
you can easily share it
with other people in your team.
JOSHUA CHA: That's right.
To do so, you just click
on the sharing icon
and list your teammates that
you want to share it with.
That's it.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Great.
I mean, this looks really good.
And I can definitely
see how developers
can use it to start pulling out
business logic from their data.
Before we sign
off, I just wanted
to circle back and
discuss a little bit more
about advanced
analytics that you can
do on the Intel-based gateways.
So the type of data that
we're able to visualize here,
and really in almost all
Cloud-based frameworks,
is limited to what you can
send via JSON, so numbers,
like floats or integers,
and strings of characters.
This works great for
many data applications.
Our demo here uses
sensor data, which
is encoded as an integer
value between 0 and 1023,
which is a pretty standard
way of doing analog
to digital conversion.
But what if the data
that you're gathering
can't be encoded into
a number or a string?
So for instance, more
and more applications
are based around
gathering video or images.
And the only way to send
an image with a JSON
would be to break it up into
an array of pixel values.
And this can be both cumbersome
and very bandwidth intensive.
So what you need to
do then is some kind
of advanced
analytics at the edge
before we can send that
data up to the Cloud.
So Intel provides a whole
host of tools for just that
with the Intel System Studio.
This is an IDE for C++ that
integrates a whole host
of libraries and SDKs, which
are created by Intel and meant
for advanced analytics.
Checkout
software.intel.com/system-studio
to learn more, download the
IDE, and just start using it
and applying it
to your projects.
One of the tools that's
included in this package
is the Computer Vision SDK.
So this SDK was released
into public beta
about a month or so
back and integrates
a bunch of really useful
tools for Computer Vision
applications.
It's based around OpenCV,
which is an open source
project for Computer
Vision, originally developed
at Intel back in 2000.
It's grown quite
a bit since then,
thanks to an extremely
active developer community.
The CV SDK expands on the
capabilities of OpenCV
by adding in optimizers, deep
learning, a visual algorithm
designer, and a lot more tools.
And of course, it's been
optimized to run on Intel CPUs.
So what does this mean
in terms of our Dataflow?
Well, it means that instead
of sending up an entire image,
you can analyze it with
the CV SDK on the gateway,
and then send a data format
that's easy for our pipeline
to ingest.
And in this way you can
expand the kinds of data
that you can use in
your application.
JOSHUA CHA: That's
all we have for today.
We hope that today's
session shows
that with the combined power
of Intel's hardware platforms
with Google Cloud
you too can build
a highly scalable,
reliable data pipeline.
MARTIN KRONBERG: And
please stay tuned
for our next webinar
in which we're
going to demonstrate
how you can use
this data to build your own
machine learning solutions.
Thanks, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSHUA CHA: Welcome back.
We hope you enjoyed
the presentation.
And thank you for
your questions.
We've gathered a
number of questions
that we hope we can answer.
To start off, let's start
with number one here.
How do you charge for BigQuery?
Query Now, there are three
dimensions to BigQuery pricing.
The first one is storage.
The second one is streaming.
And the third is the query.
On the storage side,
we charge about $0.02
per gigabyte per month.
On the streaming side,
we only charge a cent
per 200 megabytes per month.
And on the query side, it's
$5 per terabyte of query,
with the first
terabyte being free.
Now, data coming into BigQuery
and data coming out of BigQuery
is free.
So if you have any
questions, there's
more information on the website
under BigQuery in the Google
Cloud platform website.
Number two, another
BigQuery related question.
You only showed
BigQuery using a UI.
Is that the only way to
interface with BigQuery.
The answer is no,
there's multiple ways.
The first way is through our
REST APIs, very well-known
REST APIs.
The second way is through out
G Cloud command line interface.
The third way, and I would
say the most popular way
people are interfacing
with BigQuery,
is through our native APIs.
So we do have APIs built
for Python, .NET, and Java.
So as a developer,
you have your options
on how you want to leverage
BigQuery into your project.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: Cool.
Here's a question
on sensor libraries.
So the question is,
how do I learn more
about sensor libraries
used on the Intel device?
So Intel actually maintains a
website called the upm.mraa.io.
It has all the information about
the sensor libraries, the APIs,
which sensors you could use.
This site was recently
revamped, so you
should be able to access
all this information.
It should be easily accessible.
Again, the website
is upm.mraa.io.
JOSHUA CHA: Great.
Thank you, Sundar.
Number four, how much
does Data Studio cost?
So there's a theme here.
Developers are
concerned about cost.
The good news about
Data Studio is
that it's a free product as
the date of this recording.
And it's currently in beta,
so it's a free product.
However, I do want to inform our
developer community out there
that if you're using
BigQuery as the data store
to serve the data
into Data Studio,
you will be charged for the
querying and the storage
of that BigQuery
data, so watch that.
But the product itself
today is a free product.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: Cool.
JOSHUA CHA: Let's see.
OK.
All right.
Great.
Number five, another Data
Studio related question.
It's a great question.
Aside from the built-in
data connectors,
are there third party connectors
available for Data Studio?
And the answer is yes.
If you Google Data Studio
community connectors,
you'll get a result--
the first result will be a
page where we allow and educate
developers to create their
own Data Studio connectors.
So if the standard built-in
connectors don't do it for you,
you build your own.
And you use a product
called App Script, which
is beyond the scope
of this webinar.
But it's pretty easy
to pick up as well.
There's tons of
information online.
In addition to that
community page,
we actually have
a gallery as well
for our third parties
who have already
created these connectors.
That gallery is linked
off this community page.
So again, search for Data
Studio community connectors.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: Excellent.
Here's a question
on device security.
So are there any
specific tools that
help increase device security?
Actually, there are.
In fact, very recently at
the IoT World Conference,
we announced a special
feature called a secure device
onboarding.
Take a look at it.
More information is
available at www.intel.com/se
curitydeviceonboarding.
With features like
secure device onboarding,
you can actually onboard
a device securely
with pretty much zero touch.
So you don't have to ship
devices with a default
username and password.
That's a huge security risk.
So again, the website
link is www.intel.com/se
curitydeviceonboarding.
JOSHUA CHA: Great.
Another IoT device
related question which is,
with IoT devices, we
can have thousands
deployed in the field.
How many topics and subscribers
can I have in my GCP project?
So a great question because,
again, with IoT devices
you tend to work at scale.
Right?
So within each project,
each can contain up
to 10,000 subscribers--
MARTIN KRONBERG: Wow.
JOSHUA CHA: --and 10,000 topics.
So hopefully, that's
enough for your use.
And lastly, how long will data
be stored in a Pub/Sub topic?
Well, obviously, acknowledged
messages will be removed
from the queue immediately.
However, messages will persist
in that queue for up to seven
days before they'll be removed.
So hopefully within
that seven day window,
you'll be able to
take that Pub/Sub
data as shown in
the presentation
and move it into some sort of
persistent storage solution.
Right?
Like BigQuery.
With that, we finished
up the Q&A portion
of the presentation.
We'd like to thank you
on behalf of Sundar,
Intel and google would
like to thank you
for joining today's broadcast.
We hope you learned a lot.
And we appreciate your
time this morning.
Thank you.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: Thank you.